here's when et first met Jenny McCarthy
and Donnie Wahlberg I got everything
that you could ask for and I'm only 21
years old I mean for a kid who grew up
in Dorchester with nothing you know with
food stamps and no money in my pocket
man that's that's really something man
it goes
kids are our peers they're not just our
fans and stuff the attention in the
adulation I mean is wonderful
the girls just kissing me all right and
it feels good believe me when they be
kissing all on Donnie designed the
clothes wrote some songs and the band's
name New Kids on the Block came from one
of his rap songs they were originally
called Nana felt like they attacked his
signature look became long hair no shirt
and some very memorable dance moves
growing up I had fights all the time I
had incidences all the time but now I'm
a new kid on the block I'm so famous and
the press has given us this goody
two-shoes image but we never claimed to
be good we just claimed to be positive
Donnie always gave his all onstage so
much that during a June concert in 1990
he fell through a trapdoor on stage and
ended up in the hospital just a few days
later he was back I never changed my
stage performance you know I may look a
few places before I leave Donnie's
younger brother Marc was one of the
original members of NKOTB but he left
early on the two gave et a private
concert in 1992 just a couple years
later is when et first met Jenny
McCarthy Haiti you think this could be
my big break the then 21 year old had
just been named Playboy's Playmate of
the Year we went home with Jenny to
Chicago and met her family I know a lot
of playmates have have made you know
made it big and actresses and
supermodels and fortunately that's
exactly the way it worked for me
Jenny definitely hit it big and she
found true love with Donnie he proposed
in 2014 with this giant yellow sapphire
ring I'll do this six years later the
two are still going strong their secret
I love you and we work this
work we love each other it's fun but we
put in the time
[Music]